僕人は儲けがない甘くなくなってちょっと待ってると
よまず骨とか折れたらまずもう居能そちらをたがこの頃から外れ社長の庄内実験今
こげ茶どうかたはじめな今日用意するのはこちらへ
まず用意するのはこちらを束ねる水です一時期結構なんと話題になったと思うんです
けどもう is がつかめるというものでございます
実際に持っててこれで水自体をつかめるっていうかこれどう
この水がつけられているのかと言いますと
分かりません2じゃこっちだ ultra ever dry 骨骨なんか結構使われ
てたんですけども何かと言いますと水は完全にあずきようになるらしいてございますね
すごいな完全に水をはじく付でこれはこれがかかると基本的にもう全く水が入らなく
なるらしいです
使える溝そらまあ多分水とかに行こうとしてもその後沈んでいくんですよ水だからなん
ですけどもしこの2
ガメルにずうに good ライバードで全部かけて完全暴追された水を水の上に置く
と果たしてどうなのかという実験でございますありすごくないだってさ普通に考えて
いる水の弾く水辺ちょっとした水の上で水がを取るかもしれない
混ざることであろう2つの物質が混ざらないとかたしてどのようなことが起きるのかと
いう実験でございます今回はこんなよゼニアいないけどちょっと複雑なんだ
けど味噌弾くつかめる水をつくってその水浴軸つかめる水を水の故に能くとどうなるの
かという実験でございますやることだ
高度になってきたぞつかめる店の人まで作っていきましょう
あと rb 3 c を作ろうっっまず good とぬるま湯を入れなきゃー
ないタワーを持ったばいい
まあまあ満々まあまあふたを閉めて溶けるまで降りますだいたい10分
10分10分5分の
eye 視力なったらでこれで20分ほど放置すると透明になるらしいです
[音楽]
バッハ
ドゥルガーいればいい気持ちいいって言ってからて画面で作れたらティックっていいん
じゃなーいすごいピュロスもっと良いカヌー ahkah レアてぃ言ってりゃいいて
きて植えてきて路沿い
外れて
[音楽]
アーサー知らせすればいいんじゃねこれほらもう完全にほらをくらげくらげ
かレシーブしに長く漬けておくと硬くなってますなぁ
もういいんじゃないでもホラー4階は我々は来てる人にする配管やいい
こんな感じでとまでつかめる水が完成しました愛的で使えビズが準備できたので今から
このつかめる水にグルドライバーとれって完全防水をしていきますそれ本当によって
このつかめに水は完全防水された水になってしまいますので
完全防塵だった水を
水の上にのせれば果たしてどうなるのかミスみようと思います
よいしょっと得るドライバーでかけていきます
お問い合わくね
これでこれが乾燥した後にこっちをかけます
[音楽]
はいというわけで a 無事
コーティングが出来たんですけどもうこれもアウトじゃない実際まあはれたとかな
ウンガー者 by 野望はれ中身がないっていう人なんてこれはコーティングされてる
んで深める水には変わりないんだよはこれだけの成功ですから
はいの車でいっぱいはい
その後コーティングしないパートのかなコーティングじゃないバージョン入れる等
もうなじみ砂で沈んでいっちゃいますね沈んじゃいますね
水に沈んざいます次は農水のコーティングしてるんですからそれで受けばう決まって
くるはずいてれば今噛みつけば
シェイこそ存じますう3
2わー
かいきます
はい
はいありがとうございません re
me
うううう
uh
me
ana あああっ
ええええええ
とってくるリアム